I banish thee from Salem forever  [Music]  the right to fear thee magic has a way  of uniting happy 16th birthday child  I have a gift from my favorite customers  Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday  that a witch gets her powers  [Applause]  [Music]  Gilbert where did you get that candle we  have to get out of here the witch will  be here any second the book is alive he  woke up  if we intend to live past Sunrise we  have to steer this so whoa whoa wait can  we talk about this no  we must fly  not to freak out the provincial Maniac  obsessed with getting revenge on Salem  so  we should get some salt why so it tastes  better when they eat us  [Music]  [Music]  that's not Six Feet Under  stop I am a good zombie  [Music]